Unfortunately, the world did not begin the New Year in peace, but in distress.
In my view, particularly the Middle East has been the main issue so far.
The leaders of the world have been late in paying attention to the Middle East.
In spite of the recent cease-fire declared, to ease the situation quickly, I believe that about 1300 civilians have been killed and more than 5000 have been injured in the Middle East.
The infrastructure of Gaza has been totally destroyed.
The superstructure has been seriously damaged.
To address this, we, as world leaders, should try  to find out how we can contribute to peace in the Middle East.
Especially following the new presidency in the US which started on the 20th of January, I believe President Obama will interpret the Middle East issue and the peace efforts in the region in a different manner.
As a matter of fact, I would expect that Mr. Obama will be the voice of the silent majority in the Middle East and also offer his help to those who need it in the region.
Here I would like to state that the Republic of Turkey is always ready to do its utmost to contribute to the peace efforts in the Middle East.
And I hope that Davos will pave the way for significant changes in the peace efforts of the world.